- She's like, "No, I don't--
I don't--
I don't think we can."
I'm like, "Why?"
And she goes, "I think--
I think my vagina's too small."
And first off, that's fucked up.
Like, all you have to say is,
"I think your dick is too big."
[laughter]
[dark electronic music]
- [gagging]
♪
[electronic whirring]
[alarm blaring]
♪
[explosion booms]
[cheers and applause]
- Welcome
to "This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir.
Tonight all the stories
are about disasters.
[cheers and applause]
You know him from
the "Nerd of Mouth" podcast.
Please give it up for
Mr. Mike Lawrence, everybody.
[cheers and applause]
♪
- I'm gonna talk for a second
about my hands.
They're glistening.
I have the worst handshake ever.
You want to shake my hand?
Is that not the most
disgusting handshake
you've ever felt
in your life, right?
I have Edward Jizzerhands.
They are disgusting.
And the reason why is,
I am perpetually nervous
and terrified,
because my experiences
with women,
growing up, were awful.
I'm first gonna tell
you about the first time
I ever said "I love you."
It was in an AOL chat room,
of course.
Ba-duh.
My screen name was Poetic15,
because I was a poetic
15-year-old,
and I wanted the world
to knows it.
And also, AOL rejected my first
screen name,
TheJizzBlossoms.
[laughter]
And I'm in this chat room.
I'm spouting my poems,
and this girl, IguanaLover69,
comes in,
which is just proof she's better
than the first 68 iguana lovers,
and she's like,
"Hey, I like your poems."
I'm like, "Why don't we
move this to a private chat?"
[singing funk tune]
And I realize that sounds
more like a Seinfeld-based
guitar,
and less like
an erotic-based guitar.
"Hey, girl, let's fuck."
[imitating Seinfeld riff]
[laughter]
So we're in this private chat.
I'm like, "What are you into?"
She's like, "Poetry."
I'm like, "Me too.
Like, what else?"
She's like, "Comic books."
I'm like, "Me too.
Who's your favorite superhero?"
She's like, "Batman."
I'm like, "Me too.
So obscure."
Then I'm like, "Is there
anything else you're into?"
She's like,
"You and your smile,"
and I'm like, "I love you."
27 minutes in.
It was time-stamped.
And I was like,
"Why don't we meet up
at a coffee shop sometime?"
She's like, "Why don't I
meet you at your place?
At 164 Paradise Way."
I'm like, "How do--how do you
know where I live?"
She's like, "I know
many things about you,
including your father's
credit card information."
So then I have to type out
"Oh, my God,"
because "OMG"
hadn't been invented yet.
Rough times.
And...
I bring in my dad.
He is furious.
My dad cancels
all of his credit cards.
30 minutes later,
we get a knock at the door.
It's my brother,
and he just goes,
"IguanaLover69, bitches."
[laughter, applause]
I was incestuously chat-fished.
[laughter]
And the worst thing
about this was,
me and my brother
were never close growing up
because I thought he never
understood me as a person,
and in the 27 minutes
I talked to IguanaLover69,
he said everything I ever wanted
to hear someone say.
[laughter]
And that is the worst
possible feeling,
to realize that your brother
is a fucking douche bag
but an incredible listener.
[laughter]
And so I was 15
when that happened,
and I was traumatized,
and at that point,
I was like,
"I just want to find real love
"attached to a real,
actual person
that isn't my brother,"
and it happened
a few months later.
And I--I met a girl named Beth,
and we started to go out,
and we're sitting
on a pickup truck
one day, making out.
This was Florida.
That's how you dos.
And she was like, you know.
She was like, "This is great,"
and I'm like, "Yeah, it is,"
and I'm like, "So--so
when are we gonna do it?"
'Cause that's what people say
before they do.
You know, "getting busy,"
"do it."
No one who's actually fucking
says those things,
just horny teenagers.
And she was like,
"I don't like the idea
of something inside me,"
and I was like,
"Okay, that sounds great.
Let's stay together,"
and we did,
for six more years.
We never had sex once.
Now, the weirdest part
about this
is being able to look
at these women
and just see them go,
"Yeah, I could believe that.
I completely understand."
Wait, isn't she
the protagonist now?
I know, it was a--it was a--
it was a tough thing.
It--that is not
a good combination
when one person's prudish
and the other is respectful.
That never works out.
So I'm gonna talk you
through the years
of our relationship.
We started in 2000, 2001.
'Cause I always believed
that it would happen.
I was like,
"This is gonna fuckin' happen."
2001, got my hand over
the right boob,
over the shirt.
2002, under the shirt.
Yeah!
2003, left boob.
Even let me get both in
at the same time.
It was amazing.
Like, she basically, like,
made me, like,
explore the boobs
in installments.
Like, she "Kill Bill"-ed me
on the boobs.
She was like, "I could
release this as one,
"but, you know what,
I'm gonna make him wait for it
and make more money."
That marketing genius.
So--and that's the thing.
It's like,
I got to the first base,
but I think, like,
I don't think, like,
I--I hit to first base.
I think, like, I--
I was walked there.
You know?
Like, I got there
on a technicality
when it takes that long.
2004, finally,
I get to--I get
to touch under the panties.
She--she touches my dick
for the first time.
Now, this is the thing.
It didn't get hard at all,
because at that point,
it was like
an old man waiting in the DMV
who just believed
his number was never
gonna be called at all.
"Oh, wait, it is me?
Oh, shit.
What am I here for again?"
[laughter]
And so I'm touching around
the--the--the pantie region,
and the thing you must know
about this girl, Beth,
is that her father lived
next door--
in the room next door,
even though her parents
had divorced.
He was just, like, a sad man
who listened to one song
and would sing it out loud,
because it helped him reconcile
with the divorce,
and that song was
"A Long December"
by the Counting Crows.
And I need to believe--
and I have no proof of this,
but I need to believe
that the moment
that she pulled the pantie aside
so that I could stick
my finger in
after four years
of being with her
is the moment in the song
where Adam Duritz goes...
♪ Yeah
[laughter]
And it was an amazing feeling.
I didn't see--I was like--
like, we were both on the bed,
like, looking like this,
you know,
like, looking through,
like, a kid's pillowcase
for trick-or-treat candy,
and all you pull out
is Tootsie Rolls.
You're like,
"I wanted real food."
And then it was like, so--
so we're gonna--
we're gonna have sex now.
She's like,
"Yeah, let's try it."
So we go--
we go to the pharmacy,
and I send her in to buy
the condoms.
I can't buy condoms, because--
I mean, look at me.
Like, I feel so bad
for that cashier
that would have to imagine me
having sex.
Like, she's making $8.75
an hour.
She doesn't want to
also have to deal with--
[groans]
[laughter]
So she goes in.
She buys a 12-pack of condoms.
I was like, "Why did you buy
a 12-pack?
That's pretty optimistic."
She's like, "It was on sale."
I'm like, "Oh, that's why
we've been together."
[laughter]
We go--we go home,
and I'm literally, like, I--
I try to--to put it in,
and she's like, "No, I don't--
I don't--I don't think we can."
I'm like, "Why?"
And she goes, "I think--
I think my vagina's too small."
And first off, that's fucked up.
Like, all you have to say is,
"I think your dick is too big."
[laughter]
I get to feel great
about myself,
and I'm still
not gonna fuck you,
because I'm not an awful person,
and I'm just like,
"Watch out, ladies.
"It's 'Excalibur.'
Who is worthy?"
So we just sit there the rest--
the rest of the day,
and we last together for--
for one more year.
We try to spice things up
one more time.
It was January 14th,
my birthday,
2005.
She buys erotic dice.
She's like, "Let's--let--
let's try something different."
You guys--you guys know
erotic dice?
So it's two dice, always.
One dice is, like, a verb,
and it's always, like,
"peruse" or "tickle,"
and the other
is a body part like
"earlobe" or "tummy."
Like, they--they--they
sound like they're all, like,
manufactured
by a Midwestern couple
who hasn't touched each other
at all in years.
"Let's peruse the tummy,
don't you know,"
you know?
"We're more frigid
than the winters in Minnesota."
So I--I roll the dice,
and I get "lick inner thigh,"
and I'm like, "Yeah."
I'm excited, 'cause you know,
I--I never--
[stammering]
I never saw her vagina,
and I'm like, "I'm gonna
finally fuckin' see it."
And she goes, "Yeah, sure,
but I'm not taking
my jeans off."
[laughter]
And I proceeded to go
down and rough
in that corduroy muff.
[mumbling]
I was like, "This is--
this is pretty good,
you know, this is."
I had 100% cotton mouth.
And...
as I'm doing it, she's like,
"You know what?
"I don't think
this is gonna work.
We should break up,"
and then I have to lift
my head above, like...
[mumbling]
"Are you sure about that?
We deserve to be
more than friends."
And we--we--we--
we broke up,
and that always bothered me,
the fact--
I'd never--
I never saw her vagina.
Six years in, some of this,
some of that,
never saw her vagina.
So, after six years,
her vagina became, like,
Wilson from "Home Improvement"
to me.
[laughter]
There were glimpses of it,
but because I never got
to truly see it for what it was,
I gave it a power and wisdom
it didn't deserve.
[laughter]
By the end, I didn't even want
to eat her out.
I just wanted to seek guidance,
you know?
So the epilogue to this is--
so we broke up.
I called her about a month later
to see how she was doing.
She was like,
"Yeah, I've had sex.
It's pretty good."
I'm like, "What?"
She's like, "Remember all
those times I said that it was--
"it was me and not you?
I think it was you
the whole time."
And I was like, "All right,"
and I was upset,
but then I was like,
"You know what, though?
I'm gonna--
I'm gonna one-up you."
So I went on the dating website
"PlentyOfFish."
It's a dating website named
for one of Jesus'
lesser superpowers.
[laughter]
And I was like, "I'm gonna
find myself a woman
who's seen some things."
I found--
found a woman named Gladys.
That is an out-of-model person.
The Gladys factory
hasn't produced new product
in over 35 years.
There's just an old man outside
like, "No one goes
in the Gladys factory."
Her name--her name was Gladys.
It was intense.
Like, she fuckin'--
she was crazy.
She--she sat on my face,
which after not seeing a vagina
for six years,
and then just seeing
too much vagina.
It'd be like
if your first movie
was all four Michael Bay
"Transformers" movies.
Nothing at all--
too much!
She was--
she was intense--
she, like, smacked my balls.
She was, like, she slobbered.
She was like,
"Does Baby want some?"
And you know what, like,
it was crazy at the time,
but it was perfect,
because at that point,
I was like, "You know what?
"I'm not just gonna
lose my virginity.
I'm going to throw it away."
Thank you so much, guys.
♪